voir l'hôtel design
or après il ya eu l'euro 2000 et jouer
tous les matches c'est facile de garder
sa motivation après un tel doublé le
mondial et l'euro 2000 voix parce que la
victoire est tellement belle
mais on a toujours envie d'en avoir
nouveau quoi vous dit le football est ma
passion aujourd'hui on me paye très cher
mais sur mes payer 15000 hall par moi
j'aurais continué c'est à dire que oui
si j'avais dû jouer en troisième
division bon pareil de la même manière
ceci étant vous gagnez cas beaucoup plus
que ça je peux plus
meiway millions par mois petit peu plus
peut-être aussi vous connaissez le prix
d'un litre d'essence
paul hembery modèles diesel le premier
alors c'est important image pour un
footballeur parce que vous vous dites en
fait que bon madonna à la fin un peu le
plan sexy pour vendre pour vendre des
albums george michael à l'époque où il
était avec wam
il a avoué pas sur l'homosexualité parce
que ça lui aurait fait perdre des ventes
vous dit que finalement pour un
footballeur c'est moins grave parce que
ce qui compte c'est ce qui se passe sur
le terrain
je ne joue pas je suis pas certain que
le climat
finalement des footballeurs doit être
doit être arrangé ou ouais je dire la
réalité ça reste le terrain est tout
autre et que c'est intéressant l'image
que la zidane aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'elle est hyper positive
il y en a d'autres qui ont une image qui
est un petit peu plus décalé par rapport
à lui vous vous avez une image un peu
hautaine un peu arrogante non c'est ma
manière d'être je dire les gens c'est
parce que bon j'ai eu deux ou trois
petits accrochages avec les journalistes
enfin c'est une façon de se protéger
c'est que les gens viennent pas vous les
gens ils savent que là tout d'abord du
moulin que d'autres peut-être non voilà
on l'a tous les mois ils savent qu'on
pouvait envoyer balader puisque je
n'avais rien à faire alors j'ai donné
parler ici de la semaine dernière de la
façon dont les noirs sont prêtés dans la
société française dans les médias etc
est ce que vous vous avez souffert du
racisme tout simplement non pas vraiment
directement comme ça non et vous pensez
par exemple que la télévision vous
pourrez quelqus de noir tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus mais est ce que
vous pensez qu'il faudrait des quotas
que les chaînes de télévision soit
obligé de
d'engager des animateurs noir du
présentateur du journal télévisé noir le
problème de quotas bon forcément fait qu
on va on va aller les rechercher alors
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément le talent
quand même l'idée c'est vrai que ce
serait d'être un petit peu plus ouvert
au lieu de penser aux quotas mais c'est
vrai qu'il y en a pas suffisamment quand
on compare par rapport à l'angleterre
puisque je vis en angleterre on
s'aperçoit qu'ils aient une grande
différence quoi oui on voit pas de
téléfilm par exemple où il ya
essentiellement des noirs aussi on voit
pas de couple noirs s'embrassent et
aussi en france ne voit pas de
présentateur noir va pas franchi encore
le pas petit à petit